well we can ... Mrs. Mays have you always
been a giant fan no I happened some other
team you root for people yes the Yanks and
Joe DiMaggio well he is Marguerite's gonna
go along with you to spring training no I don't
think so I think I'll let us stay here and take
care of the house that I bought on how to
6th 8th Street what about a honeymoon do
you plan to go away at all no it's too close
to baseball so you know I don't think I need
a honeymoon right now possibly after the season
sure maybe after season be great Willy how long
have you two been engaged engaged I don't
believe it then I just think of that if I
want to get married I just go right ahead I
just decided maybe this matter we could go
mrs. Mays why don't you give Wally
little kiss for the television audience
good luck